Campbell's has been making condensed
soup since the 1800s its soups are also
an ingredient in a famous side dish that
we all love green bean casserole a
holiday favorite Mark Strassman visited
Campbell's headquarters in New Jersey
and found a company looking to the
Future while honoring its past
Els everyone knows Campbell's warm soup
warm Memories the red and white can that
jingle
[Music]
Campbell's soup now in his 125th year
celebrated by Andy Warhol also known for
a Timeless holiday dish green bean
casserole is it extremely simple this
recipe only has six ingredients Omar
Rivera one of Campbell's corporate chefs
so we're starting by adding our soup
I'm sure you would say the key
ingredient of course it's of course the
magic ingredient cream of mushroom soup
Campbell's created this recipe seven
decades ago this is going to be for 25
minutes or until it's hot and bubbly a
classic for a reason yeah that is good
isn't it yeah
Campbell's ladles out condensed soup
like no one else dominating with 80
percent of the market Campbell's is one
of the most iconic Brands so what's
unique about camels is they've really
relied on their tradition these are our
actual Founders that is Joseph Campbell
and Abraham Anderson Scott Hearn the
company's archivist explains Campbell
was a veggie vendor Anderson a
commercial canner nothing fancy at first
selling tomatoes in cans like this then
soup this is beef steak tomato in 1897
in a food first John Dorrance cooked up
a formula for canning condensed soup
stirring soup sales for decades this is
the first iteration of the now famous
yes label 1898 35. that labels changed
subtly a dozen times over the years you
don't mess with an icon 80s and 90s and
today I've known Campbell's my whole
life Mark Klaus has two growing up
chicken noodle soup meant you know kind
of warm home cold day today Klaus is
Campbell's president and CEO it's a
piece of American History he showed us
something special himself and so the
relationship with with Andy I think is
actually a pretty special one this 1962
Andy Warhol original worth millions
initially the company was suspicious
protective of its brand then warhol's
Campbell series went the 1960s version
of viral and I think the team at the
time said you know what we're going to
go with it and I guess the rest is
history I mean there's no question that
that can is Magic but when Klaus took
over as CEO in 2019 Campbell's corporate
strategy had fizzled would you say that
soup had been left behind yeah I think
soup always is going to be a an
important part of the business the
future of the company was pointed
further away from that core portfolio
and that was a mistake I think it was I
think the idea of playing through our
brand instead of maybe around Our Brands
was really the way we kind of attacked
the situation to get the business built
back rejuvenated with a Back to Basics
approach Campbell sold one billion cans
of soup last year eating in during the
pandemic helped the company's new
challenge younger consumers not
necessarily soup consumers we're in a
new day a new moment new consumer needs
how are we going to make these
businesses relevant but no one's looking
for a new chicken noodle soup no if all
of the people that have asked me for
things I don't think anyone said hey why
don't you go change that chicken noodle
soup knowing when to change but what to
leave alone in the competitive business
of food
[Music]
gold for CBS mornings Mark Strassman
Camden New Jersey